good afternoon and welcome to a world
leaders forum event co-sponsored with
the School of International and public
affairs want to thank Dean John
cotesworth and his faculty for their
ongoing contributions to this particular
forum but also to the world leaders
forum in general we are joined here
today by the president of Turkey
president ghoul and by first lady ghoul
mr. president and mrs. gool welcome to
Colombia I want to
want to welcome as well all the members
of the Turkish delegation traveling with
the president who are here with us
including several ambassadors and
deputies from turkeys Parliament two
years ago Turkish Prime Minister Erewhon
came to Colombia to address this forum
and we welcome this opportunity to
continue a dialogue with a very
significant nation we launched the world
leaders forum in 2003 as a
university-wide initiative to support
serious dialogue on the most pressing
economic political environmental and
social questions of the time questions
that with each passing year seemed to
have larger and larger global dimensions
over the past seven years the forum has
offered an opportunity for more than
15,000 students faculty and staff to
directly engage with important figures
from 48 nations representing every
corner of the world the role of
universities in creating a space for
uninhibited and critical discussion of
controversial issues is fundamental to a
Democratic Society this is all the more
true when other forums in the society
seem less and less capable of having
difficult conversations today's address
from President Ghul marks the final
event in a week of world leaders forum
events on the campus coinciding with the
fall meeting of the UN General Assembly
and we have heard from a broad and
diverse group of leaders from Africa
Europe and Asia they have challenged us
with our views and I think it's fair to
say certainly Columbia students have
challenged them which is just as it
should be for many decades Americans
have viewed the nation of Turkey as a
metaphorical bridge linking the west and
the Muslim world
a rather obvious and inescapable
viewpoint ouran principally of turkeys
geography and location many Turkish
people it must be said however prefer to
think of their home not as a connective
thread but as a centre in and of itself
a view that in many respects has proved
to be the more accurate today turkey is
defined not so much by geography but by
a host of cross-cutting tensions many of
them with historic dimensions and global
implications and many that are now being
addressed through Turkey's political
system at times that process has been
passionate inconclusive bruising and
dramatic but that is no different from
the way democracies around the globe
routinely struggle with issues of
consequence president Ghul helped found
the Justice and Development Party known
as AKP in 2001 and was elected president
of Turkey in August of 2007 today he
leads the nation with the fastest
growing economy in Europe less than two
weeks ago a referendum supported by his
government was approved by fifty eight
percent of Turkish voters it mandated
the adoption of a package of
constitutional reforms affecting the
operation of the judiciary the
prerogatives of the military privacy
rights and the rights of women children
the elderly and the disabled the vote in
Turkey was closely observed and has
generated a myriad of opinions and
critiques the issues turkey turkey is
grappling with our emblematic of many of
the most urgent concerns facing
countries around the globe at this
moment in history such as the
intersection of economic development and
geopolitics the clash of can
and secular cultural value values often
revealed in the political realm as a
competition between rural populations
and urban elites the interconnectedness
of democratic reforms human rights and
independent judiciary and a
well-functioning Free Press the
alignment between government policy and
commercial interests and the challenge
of preserving sovereignty in a global
society that must increasingly rely upon
regional and international governing
bodies the address the president will
deliver is titled what next Turkey's
vision global vision for a prosperous
future the question of what is next in
turkey is to say the least of great
interest through all of us here today
and to people throughout the world
please welcome the president of Turkey
president
mr. president dear students
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen it is a great pleasure to be
here at Columbia University today I
greet you all professors as well as
students and guests and thank those who
made this occasion possible for me this
morning before coming here I give a
speech at the Council on Foreign
Relations on touch American relations
here at Columbia I would rather talk
about my country the progress be
accomplished in recent years in Turkey
first and then talk about our global
vision for a prosperous future then I'll
be answering all of your questions
whatever you wish every time I come to
New York I deserve part of my busy
schedule to his book shops not only do i
update myself with the latest titles I
also find opportunity to have an idea
about the current issues discussed this
time distinct the book shops one of the
books that caught my attention was death
of Professor Bollinger user and
inhabited robust and wide open the Free
Press for a new century I very excited
can't through the chapters I didn't have
time to read all I have to admit this
year as the examples he gave from
different court cases were
of concern to any protocol leader
striving to analyze the limits of
freedom of speech I agree with Professor
Bollinger when he says that threat to
free press comes not from financial
difficulties but rather from the
national and international barriers to
gathering at reporting the news I agree
with him and this is why turkeys lost
the key in which I have been a part of
the political leadership has seen an
incredible opening and liberalisation
for freedom of speech despite many
difficulties and despite some segments
of our society still skeptical about it
Turkey has taken huge steps for securing
freedom of speech the things that were a
tableau five years ago a lot was spoken
today yet I'm not sure whether this
change is perceived fully out of Turkey
the most solid example of the strength
in the Turkish media environment was
what i should call the organization of
medial nation not too long ago the
Turkish media work consists of a couple
of media tycoons which led a rather
monopolistic power in shaping the agenda
today there are so many groups each with
the attendance nine today there is a
very rich and colorful media scene in
Turkey there are more than 14 national
TV channels hundreds of local ones and
Madrid of these channels broadcast to
the whole world by a settler the total
did circulation of nation
papers reach 4.5 million copies but
considering our nation's media literacy
habits we know that the newspaper copy
is read at least by six people there are
hundreds of radio channels national and
local internet infrastructure and users
is breaking cause turkey is the country
with the highest number of facebook
users after english-speaking countries
my Twitter account is continuously being
followed discussed de pivoted many times
twitter is a more direct source of
knowledge for me than report added yes
we do have some problems on internet
some global sides our Phoebe number are
unreachable in Turkey a couple of days
ago this was us Terry at the CNN year in
New York I have told them what I will
tell you now this is not something about
censorship is rather as a result of in a
decade in curiosity of a tax law and I
have been urging the government and
Parliament to update these laws as soon
as possible as always fury follows
practice not vice versa and Turkey will
not be late to update its laws a very
recent example is a clear proof of the
fact that Turkey is acting fast in this
respect Matt far I go one would face
investigation and trials should be even
mention about the freedom to speak
different spoken languages
one of which is Kurdish letting
broadcast in Kurdish today other than
many private Kurdish language chance
broadcasting PRT our state television
has a Kurdish broadcasting channels
around the clock aside the Arabic and
turkey language PRP channels today we
can talk about any issue discuss about
any team in Turkey without any
limitation and borders as a result of a
to Center long evolving progress for
pluralism and democracy turkey now
stands as a country where problems are
openly discussed and debated where civil
society drives and where freedoms human
rights at the rule of law prevail above
all yet coming to this point has not
been easy we paid to each and every
segment of Turkish society has gone
through hard times we had to question
our stand our past our actions we have
to understand that in the way for more
libraries in the rare in the road for
more freedom we are all together but
withstanding our ethnic religious leader
differences these examples and many
others can be raised as proofs of turkey
squares for more democracy more freedoms
more rule of law yet a recent
development which took place on a couple
of weeks ago was the most pleasant at
the most important on 13th of sep tember
2010 30 years after the military coup
that created a tragedy results for our
democracy Turkish nation has acts
the important Constitution and Adnan's
the proposal of a comprehensive
constitutional amendment package has
been approved by the Turkish nation by a
majority of fifty-eight percent in a
referral new seventy-seven percent of
the constancy swatted these amendments
which were praised by many from
intellectuals to EU commissioners from
lawyers to world leaders are trying
among many other things to rise the
following steps extending the borders of
personal freedoms or holding the
election methods of the judiciary
redefine it relationship between
civilian edmonton institutions
increasing number of Democratic tools
citizens can use and of course raising
the level of democratic participation
now I'm pleased to see that after this
referendum there is a growing consensus
for a new constitution and of the
political parties today speaking at
Columbia University one of the credits
of the barrel told in the world I am
proud to be the president of a country
that is continuously working for a more
democratic nation as a present of turkey
I know that we still have a long way to
go I know that we have to raise the
standards of our democracy we have to
broaden its scope we have the enhanced
man means of participation our task is
certainly not over turkey aspires to
become a world-class democracy and to
benefit from the growing prosperity
stemming from a competitive at
knowledge-based economy I tell you this
as I am
where that e steps we make these ends
the problems of today will be solved but
after another distinguished guests
ladies and gentlemen the end of Cold War
marked a new international strategy
environment in which there is an
abundance abundance of pressing issues
such as terrorism extremism energy and
food security natural disasters
epidemics frozen or active conflicts and
rebuilding distressed countries there is
also a growing recognition that finding
solutions to seemingly less tangible
issues like global warming poverty
reforming the global financial
architecture and prevented cultural
polarization is becoming increasingly
urgent with the emergency of new and
unforeseen challenges the international
system is born to you all towards a new
state of sakura bloom in the next decade
in this new global setting turkey
continues to be a constructive actor in
its region and to make positive
contribution to the establishment of a
viable new international system Turkey
has been playing a crucial role in its
multi-dimensional region that extends
the Balkans the East millet Orion the
carcasses at the Middle East and beyond
this unique your political position has
created both challenges and
opportunities for Turkey in addressing
the challenges and risks and seizing the
opportunities turkey harbours various
assets of which the most important is
its dynami and aspiring population our
most important objective is to provide
the nation
with the highest political economic and
social standards the achievement of this
objective will be highly facilitate if
stability and peace prevail in our
neighboring regions a stronger
commitment to upholding human rights and
democracy is also a central to our
common quest for peace development and
social justice in our region we should
not forget that protection and promotion
of human rights are the major element of
the resolution of today's security
challenges respect for human rights can
help prevent conflicts contribute the
sustainable development and also spoiled
poverty reduction strategies adherence
the rule of law and good governance is a
political visit for consolidation of
stability and progress across the globe
therefore turkey attach great importance
to the promotion and protection of human
rights as priority area in its national
and foreign policy agenda it's why I
have started my speech with doing
examples from our legs accomplishments
the challenges of globalization are best
at last by democratic societies is also
the message we are spreading across the
credibility of our message is pointing x
factor we have historical and cultural
ties with many nations in our
neighborhood searching for ways to
overcome deep-rooted political economy
or security problems the Armenian
opening is a very good example as you
will remember I have gone to Yerevan to
watch the football game between Armenia
and Turkey
that game was a mild storm a milestone
that looked not to the past but to the
future and I want to keep my hope that
the milestone we have accomplished it
mr. sarkizian will be taken further
hence turkey can draw upon its
cross-cultural skills in acting as an
interface that facilities dialogue among
parties in the spirit and promote
harmony across different cultures today
the Turkish influence is being felt in
the most positive manner not in the
neighborhood countries but in a global
scale Turkey's actions are being
followed carefully the last week that we
spent here in New York the clear proof
of this turkey is a source of
inspiration distinguished guests Turkish
nation is old in history but young in
demography our young dynamic end the
source for population of 72 million with
a moderate rate of growth gives Turkey a
competitive advantage in our development
efforts in order in other words Turkish
demographics are an asset for itself and
its partners including the European
Union the structural reform process in
the economy has been successful the
Turkish economy has become more
resilient to measure external or
internal shocks waves since 2002 it has
managed to stay on course in spite of
the world economy Christ's key factors
in achieving is favorable outcome were
confidence stability and predictability
just to give you a few examples
excluding 2009 the year of global crisis
the Turkish economy has grown at an
annual average rate of 7.5 percent
during the past seven years as a result
Turkey has become the 16th largest
economy in the world with a gdp fast
approaching the trillion dollar mark in
first half of 2010 turkey scored the
fastest Claude wait annatto he see the
economy's by eleven percent total trade
volume has reach 150 200 for the three
billion dollars we are destined to reach
500 billion dollar stretch old in the
coming few years foreign direct
investment if the I the turkey reach a
total of six nine billion dollars during
the last five years even in 2009 the
yield of crisis we received and if the
eye of 8.5 billion dollars if the I in
the first half of 2010 was more than
three billion dollars turkey became a
country with supplies secure energy to
Europe we have accomplished this by
divers find routes from different
sources with new pipelines part of them
already functioning part of them plan
tourism is booming 28 million tourists
visit Turkey in 2009 placing us among
total Panthers destination in the world
turkey was the only country which
increased the number of tourists
arriving during 2009 the year of crisis
all these figures and indicators are
records in themselves which could not
have even been imagined before
turkey is also making its now itself now
in the world through a renaissance in
literature art sports education and
science it's now very likely that we
will see a Turkish writers book on
bestsellers list in n of the book shops
in New York the same is valid for church
artists work which can be seen in art
galleries at saw all the church movies
are bought at Venice as well as at
Sundance the Turkish intellectuals life
is in a continuous progress our noble
love lead writer on our public has been
in column a in the past years for
lectures and I mind you it was turkey
who played the final game with the US
the last basket or world championship in
Istanbul distinguished guests turkey is
a strong NATO ally a negotiating
candidate to the European Union a member
of the organization of the Islamic
Conference and the Black Sea Economic
Cooperation Organization current chair
of the conference on interaction and
confidence-building measures in Asia
observers in the Arab League strategic
partner of the African Union and thanks
to other organizations that we are
affiliated with turkey is a network and
connected power and of course turkey is
the current chair of United Nations
Security Council which I precise
yesterday in the summit session apply
also to mention the Alliance of
civilizations launched by Turkey and
Spain five years ago the Alliance has
become second largest international
platform after the UN it
all our current efforts are aimed at
building a stronger turkey that's able
to make its distinctive contribution
between Chihuahuas bizim the Hager
tribute turkey coma kitchen in honor MK
darn JK head every miss a year I'll
yamaha takashima check ojala burgas al
anam desert around our GD g a a planter
mother turkey to columbia loin your beer
joachim on Amish in solemn shoulder
moose energy transport are some virility
Minaj Mozilla Bisbee stability ume
bastard occur between turkey cop tube in
Sultan's our marshmallow forgot Shonda a
dashiki Fergus I she wandered issues
alone we strive to usher in a better
global economy structure through our
participation in the g20 while the
knowledge diligent about issues like
carbon global warming combating
terrorism and other forms of
cross-border criminal activity ensuring
sustainable energy supplies and
educating poverty furthermore we are
keenly extending a helping hand to
underdeveloped states struggling to
overcome chronic problems without
expecting any anything in return Turkey
has evolved into an emerging toner with
the contribution of turkey-based NGOs
our overall development assistance
exceeds by a half billion dollars
annually as all these makes clear they
are driving
by a desire to make our modest
contribution to the global force towards
the betterment of mankind in all
respects in this regard I believe our
record so far as a responsible
non-permanent member of the United
Nations Security Council also speaks for
itself ladies and gentlemen so far I
talk about my country and what we
achieved the garden democratization
peace building at cooperation economic
successes as well as regarding church
accomplishments in other area of data
life Turkey's footprint at the global
level is increasing day by day turkey is
a country whose contributions can make a
difference at all levels now let me
share with you the kind of vision I have
for a better and prosperous future in
which turkey will be an active
participants I always believe that we
need to reconsider the fundamentals of
political and diplomatic language in
order to construct a more prosperous
just a future for the world this much
needed today as the drastic changes that
took place in the last couple of decades
at all have altered the basic salt
sociological definition at categories
more than anything the meaning of state
is changing today but we have called
stay is in a position to redefine the
position and rebrand itself and of
course the change is influencing what we
understood from international relations
so far altering the main definitions and
understandings the very architecture of
global policy is changing dog balances
alliances and philosophies are giving
way to new ones old membership and clubs
are losing meaning that's why there is a
continuous talks of countries shifting
access when the very meaning of the
world axis continues the changes
shifting access becomes a mere polemic
the former dichotomies of is bar service
as well as south west north ave long
calls their applicability so are the
categories of 1st 2nd and 3rd ward
revolution of internet that globally
available information has dramatically
influenced the capabilities of former
power brokers the power of media is more
heterogeneous than ever the most recent
example is that of WikiLeaks in such a
setting turkey believes that we need to
establish a new language for global
context this new language is much needed
as the old one is not cool to the
problems we are facing today Foucault
said that it was language that
determined the limits of power today for
a prosperous future we need to redefine
those limits and we can do that through
changing our language in the final part
of my speech I will shortly concentrate
on this new language which I will prefer
to call the new language of diplomacy
this new language of diplomacy should be
established not on confrontation or
domination but rather on coming together
and shaping power sharing power
furthermore it should create global
platforms were different understandings
and ways of thinking
together this new language should be
constructed not on hierarchical symbols
but on qualities and come compare and
competencies the formal categories such
as 1st 2nd and 3rd ward have to be
abandoned the new language should be
multicultural multi-dimensional and
heterogeneous unlike the formal language
which was established on a eurosceptic
perspective this new language must be
established on universal values this
name language must be inclusive not
exclusive the new language must be
written on principles and pedes rather
than on categories it must take into
consideration actions rather than
subjects of the actions the new language
shall not award winners and punished
losers it shall not pure your tries and
identities and must understand that
identities are poodle and subject to
change it's only when we are able to
establish this given language should be
able to dream about a more prosperous
future otherwise the energy we spent on
today's complex issues will be a loss
ladies and gentlemen as turkey we are
ready to and to say plastic and to a
cystic about such a process of renewal
we have the energy resources and region
to participate in such a process that's
why we continuously and trust tirelessly
talk about a new church foreign policy
no single factor alone makes search firm
policy today but a multitude of factors
we don't define ourselves with the
boundaries of a single region club
issue we strive to be active in the
areas where we feel a responsibility as
a result of our historical heritage and
universal blondie we aim to be
policymakers rather than policy applier
these three principles come together to
make what we call a call active
constructive foreign policy what makes
me comfortable today after a week full
of meeting at the schedules at the UN is
to see that the footprint of this active
and consulting foreign policy is
appreciated widely the leaders I have
met the delegations I have received the
meetings I have attended all confirm one
thing the world today is impatient for
the construction of a new international
architecture this architecture is Roy
trade in my completion this art
architecture I reiterate in my
conclusion should be established on this
entirely new language otherwise we will
continue to leave the Atlas cycle of
problems that we are living today as
Turkey we are determined to work for a
better world based on the principles of
justice equality and freedom a better
world is possible for this we need to
stand together and at a shared vision of
future as a famous song set together we
stand divided we fall thank you thank
you very much
thank you
thank you thank you very much
the president will now take questions we
have two microphones please feel free to
line up you have to speak please
identify yourself and we have
translating machines for those who
cannot understand the language in which
the question or the answer is given so
please good afternoon mr. president my
name's Kelsey Campbell I'm a graduate
students at school of international
public affairs and consequence of this
summer's Gaza Totila incident was the
major breakdown in Turkish Israeli
relations and a consequence of that was
that turkey pulled out of the bilateral
and trilateral maritime exercises in the
region and you had talked of working
with your regional partners Fortran
national threats so I see this as a
vulnerability if we're not practicing
coordination future threats okay do we
have translational types begin touch in
English we can do it either way you want
to speak whichever way you want
by minute as me talk to check on show
that soreness the ninja tabi of course
when I listen it's very logical what you
ask but let me also say that we should
also look at the reasons or actually
before looking at the reason reasons
what I'd like to say is that from the
point of view of Turkish Israeli
relations Turkish Israeli relations
since the question is relevant to that
point Turkish shoes relations that were
very strong up until a couple of months
ago turkey recognized Israel it
acknowledges its presence has been the
first country to recognize and
acknowledge its presence in the region
and we've had many good relations
long-standing relations with Israel over
the course of the years we have many
agreements that were signed between
Turkey and Israel and in fact turkey has
also worked with the Israeli Israelis
and there are countries in order to help
contribute to achieving peace and most
recent example of this effort was the
role that turkey played in trying to
have almost direct meetings between the
Israelis and the Syrians and
and their turkey worked to bring the two
sides to a common understanding but in
addition to that it if you look at other
areas economic political cultural and
military is there's always been
relations between Turkey and Israel but
in 2006 when the events took place in
Gaza before the eyes of the whole world
we were shocked by what took place
because up until a week a few days
before that situation arose in Gaza we
were working too we were working to
create an environment whereby they would
be direct talks between the Israelis and
the Syrians in order to solve problems
existing between the two countries Prime
Minister Olmert at the time was in
Turkey a few days before the events in
God's that began in 2006 there were
meetings Prime Minister they were
meeting by mr. are the one and that
there were they were the two delegations
the Syrians and Israelis were in two
different hotels and we were shuttling
back and forth between the two sides and
as we were trying to finalize those
discussions the events in Gaza took
place and they were broadcast live to
the whole world I was speaking earlier
in my speech about the world basketball
championship I'm sure you were able to
watch it on television life and in the
same way people could see then how the
people in Gaza died and how Gaza was
bombed and everyone people in the world
in the region in our country and
everyone watched what happened and it
would not have been possible in a
democratic and open society to act after
this incident as if nothing happened so
these exercises which you refer to in
the question the cancellation those
those were all as a result of all the
events that took place which I have
explained unfortunately later on there
were also other developments undesirable
dogmas and I'm sure you follow them very
closely I mean between Turkey and Israel
but let me say that this has not come
about as a result of our choice we
weren't the ones who initiated this
situation we for example the
humanitarian aid convoys in the
Mediterranean the flotilla had ships
from different countries there were
people from 33 different countries and
those were all organized by
non-governmental organizations
independent from the government's and
they were traveling towards Gaza they
were in international waters in the
Mediterranean they were 80 miles out at
sea from the Israeli coast and of course
when they are attacked and when they're
there and they're people are killed one
being a Turkish US citizen and the other
eight being Turkish citizens of course
it would not be possible to ignore these
what is taking place and I hope that all
of these issues can be resolved within
international law because international
law binds any UN member state no country
in the world today can say that they
find themselves that they can be beyond
the scope of international law that is
not possible so yes there are these
problems these problems unfortunately
arose rather quickly and we see some
repercussions as you refer to some of
them but we hope that they will be
resolved within the context of
international law so that sustainable
peace is achieved in the region and
there can be once again cooperation and
on a broad scale
Jim magani school of business im sue
president I have a question for you
regarding the freedom of press in Turkey
to mention in your speech I led that the
son-in-law of Turkish Prime Minister
forever is the CEO of chela condiment
which is if government funding for
entering the barely profitable Turkish
media stream later this conglomerate has
been very active in government in
acquiring government evolving such as
energy distribution companies do you
find oscillation shift between state
banks government leaders and media
companies particularly commendable in
modern Turkey been a push from the side
him as I've stated in my speech the
Turkish press and its plurality we're
all points are referred to the fact that
the son-in-law of the Prime Minister is
a head of a company is not something
that can be banned that's not possible
what's important is that when those
credits loans are sought the conditions
the guarantees have to be fair and that
whether or not sufficient guarantees
were presented well you know what the
interest rates are those are the kinds
of things that the one has to look at as
far as I know
this is something a lot under discussion
that's why I have also asked questions
about this because as you say this is
quite debated in Turkey and that's why I
know that in the loans were given out at
libor plus quite high interest rates and
those loans have to be repaid and as far
as I know there is no problem with
regard to the repayment of the loan
loans but what's important here is
whether or not there's any pressure on
the press as far as freedom of
expression is concerned whether or not
there is any limitation to the freedom
of expression these are all things that
are being discussed in Turkey the fact
that there is debate on these very
issues in Turkey goes to show that there
is a lot of discussion some of it very
heated and aggressive and in the sense
that it's very contentious I don't need
to say that you asked you a question in
that way but there is there is that
discussion on in that atmosphere in
Turkey which is actually a testament to
the presence of freedom of the press but
as I've said in my speech there are
still things to do i'm not saying that
we're perfect that it's all very good
and that there's nothing else you there
are still things we need to do and we
have to keep working on those of course
university as you know we have a great
tradition of critical debate here and
speaking truth to power and in light of
that ethic and following up on the first
question I'd like to ask you the
following if the ship if the flotilla
think back to the flotilla were reversed
and these were ships headed toward
separatists Kurds in Turkey towards
Kurdish turkestan what would your
government have done please before you
launch an app olymic about Israel and
Palestinian relations answer the
question of what your government have
done a visa
had refused inspection Thank You mr.
president at the sugar then was sorry
look at that thank you very much for
asking this question in this very direct
way but there is one thing that is not
correct here the Kurds are our own
citizens for a thousand years we've been
coexisting in the same geography in my
delegation here I don't know who is a
turquoise occurred or in the minister
mr. cabinet if you ask you will find out
perhaps who's what the ethnic origin of
the person is were all equal before the
law in Turkey has Turkish citizens but
there are men there were many justified
complaints because of lack of proper
democratic standards and as I i said
this myself in my speech in 1980 when
there was a military regime in Turkey it
was forbidden to speak in Kurdish so
from the point of view of lack of
democratic standards they were many
complaints and our Kurdish citizens and
there were many problems with regard to
or difficulties that the Kurdish Kurdish
citizens has but where parts of the same
country but Israelis and Palestinians
are not the same people and they are not
part of the same people and let allow me
to say that there are as occupied
territories that Israel has occupied
Gaza doesn't belong to Israel the
Palestinian territories do not belong to
therefore therefore the struggle bear
and this is the circle here are not one
on the same and now what's happening
guys uh the the cause for lifting the
blockade in Gaza the appeal for that
doesn't come just from Turkey the or
dangers that were on the flotilla but
before that you had many injuries from
Greece from Italy from the UK President
Obama a Hillary Clinton the United
Nations Russia the European Union
everyone has been making calls appeals
for the lifting of the embargo in Gaza
so here we are talking about
humanitarian aid people carrying
humanitarian aid and when we speak about
NGOs these are angels which are
sensitive to humanitarian issues because
after all it's all voluntary and people
become parts of the NGOs and they make
sacrifices from their own person and
they take part in this combo and as I
said it wasn't just Turkish people with
our people from 30 different countries
so that's one thing but then if you're
talking about fighting against terrorism
terrorism in your own soil and I'm don't
mean to speak only to the PKK that is
organized by some Kurdish people there
are also some Marxist Leninist serious
organizations or Stalinist organizations
that are formed by some clerks in Turkey
now everyone can have their own ideology
I have nothing to say to that you want a
person could be Marxist or something
else but resorting to violence and
resorting to terror and to illegal acts
is something else you have to
distinguish between the truth
Kevin Pullman and I'm from the school of
general studies mr. president occur a
consistent theme that's come up as
cultural differences as in the question
before me as turkey seeks to become a
member of the European Union and
continue to play a part in the global
economy what do you believe are the most
challenging cultural differences the
turkey will have to face and how do you
believe that they should be facing the
sugar out there thank you European Union
is a strategic vision for turkey Turkey
has chosen membership full membership to
the European Union as a strategic goal
for itself and all political parties in
Turkey support this goal the mouth as to
what is the greatest challenge in way
over this aim I'll be very open with you
here in this university atmosphere I can
tell you that the greatest challenge is
the lack of vision on the part of the
European Union because turkey is
fulfilling what it reads to do turkey
has never asked to become a part of the
European Union without completing
fulfilling the criteria that is
necessary for membership that is not
been our reclaim we have to fulfill the
criteria of the club but there are time
there are times when some Member States
of the EU engage in certain political
activities to prevent or create
obstacles in way of Turkey fulfilling
those criteria I don't need to say the
European Commission because they are
very principled in the way they conduct
the technical negotiations but as far as
the member states of the European Union
are concerned we see from time to time
that due to some political domestic
political considerations
they may opt in to act in this way they
because of their domestic considerations
they lack the vision to see Europe eat
the European Union 30 40 50 years from
the down the road so i can say very
clearly that in the world today the EU
does not have the vision currently to
play the role that it can throw around
with the weight that it has and I say
this because I see in our negotiations
process that they put for certain
artificial obstacles because what is the
negotiation process about it's about
raising the standards of the candidate
country which the European Union will
monitor and when the country fulfills
all the criteria is on the same level as
EU standards then the decision to take
that country as a member is taken then
so because there are all these obstacles
one tends to think that perhaps they are
concerned that turkey can't fulfill
these criteria and when turkey does then
perhaps they feel that it will be more
difficult to to see take turkey as a
member and let me explain what I mean
for example there are chapters in the EU
about education environment justice
systems and energy and many other topics
in all of these chapters the candidate
country changes its laws and legislation
so that that country raises its
standards to comply with the standards
of the EU and this is all done through
what is called the process of
negotiation and so we are facing some
unnecessary hurdles in our negotiations
process you ask me what is the greatest
challenge in your question to me the
greatest challenge in our membership to
the EU is to deal with this effort on
the part of the European Union too slow
Turkey's accession process to the U and
that's where the greatest challenges
thank you for me sir president my name
is Amir Shah koriyama student at school
general studies my question is actually
in regards to Iran as you said Turkey's
economy is growing and it's trade with
foreign countries is an increase now we
know that it Turkey and Iran have been
over 10 billion dollars a year trade
relations and it's expected to grow over
the years also Washington Post reporter
earlier that the Turkish is that Turkish
government's actually speaking to
Washington try to lessen the extent of
sanctions against Iranian government my
question is I want at what point does
the danger of a nuclear Iran outweigh
the benefit that turkey gets from trade
from
the bootable no of course oh this is
perhaps one of the questions that was
continuously directed at me at the time
this week that I've spent here question
about Iran and of course the turkeys no
vote to the sanctions at the UN Security
Council has made it more relevant
perhaps that people have asked me this
question this week now your question is
a topical therefore and then let me
first of all say that I'd like everyone
here to know that our country is against
nuclear weapons we absolutely do not
want to see any nuclear weapons in our
region or in a neighboring country so we
as a country do not take the nuclear
weapons issue lightly but the solution
of the nuclear of a nuclear problem or
the solution of any problem it can be in
two ways war or diplomacy we would like
to see this problem solved through
diplomacy because if there's war the war
is going to take place in our region it
will take place next door to us we
already know we already have that
experience we had that experience with
Iraq in 1990 since the first Gulf War
instability in Iraq created security
problems for 30 there was an exodus of
people mass migration to Turkey and the
this had there was also an impact on the
Turkish economy and because of the
embargo and if you look at the embargo
that was imposed on Iraq it didn't yield
any results if we go back and look today
to see what sort of effect the embargo
had
it did not punish the vents at damn
regime it punished the Iraqi people on
the one hand the Saddam regime was
punishing the Iraqi people then the
embargoes too began to punish the Iraqi
people so the people were squeezed stuck
between two difficulties so we frankly
speaking would not like to experience
st. the same difficulties in the region
therefore we are taking initiative in
way of diplomacy and we are putting in
more efforts because if all the negative
events take place they'll take place
next to us in our region if something
like this were to happen in Latin
America or some part in Asia we perhaps
would not have been as closely involved
as we are in this case we could have
perhaps expressed our position from a
distance but here we're talking about
our neighbor and in the event of war if
it came what sort of migration would
take place or how I economies would be
affected by what sort of security
concerns will arise those are the kinds
of things that we are concerned about
and therefore we have we've been working
we have been displaying extraordinary
effort if you will to overcome this
problem through the diplomatic route now
if the as far as embargoes the UN
embargo of course will bind us because
the decision on sanctions was were taken
as binding decisions and we abide by
those sanctions and this we already show
through our reports now other countries
countries impose other sanctions beyond
the sanctions all of the United Nations
and that's where we find ourselves in a
more difficult position if we were to
have zero trade as is frequently
expressed to us and we feel the pressure
for that but we are also are dependent
on for example energy we don't have gas
and oil in Turkey but we smell it from
the surrounding countries it's there but
not in Turkey so we have this this
dependence on importing energy
ninety-eight percent we import some of
the gas we import comes from Iran now if
we were to go beyond the UN sanctions
and were to become part of those other
sanctions then the situation that will
arise will be such that we will have to
pay ten billion dollars to Iran and
before the gas that we get but Iran is
going to pay nothing back on the one
hand we will have import and no export
and our foreign trade deficits will
stand then at ten billion dollars and
beyond it could be more because guess we
have an increasing demand for guests
because we have a growing economy and we
get our gas not only from Iran we get it
from Iraq from other countries too so
these also have to be taken into
consideration our policies must also
take into consideration our national
interests as well having said that
however this does not mean that we take
the nuclear issue lightly because if
your neighbor has nuclear weapons I'm
not saying that Iran is definitely
making nuclear weapons weapons but this
is an issue on the discussion there are
concerns about this and that's why we're
having all this discussion about Iran
what I'm saying is that if there is
nuclear weapons in any neighboring
country then the greatest threat
emanating from that presence would be to
neighboring countries and not two
continents far away it's like two
friends if one of them has a pistol and
the other one doesn't you wouldn't feel
comfortable if you're the one who
doesn't have the pistol
so that's why turkey has is not a
country that shows any tolerance
whatsoever to at the presence of nuclear
weapons in its neighborhood to go even
further as I said in the speech I made
at the United Nations the United Nations
has a resolution 687 in nineteen dated
1992 this is a decision of a resolution
of the UN about the nuclear free region
that's a resolution that we must follow
up on and I'm not just talking about of
course this I'm not just talking about
nuclear free area i'm also talking about
the security of Israel arab-israeli
peace and a nuclear free zone this was
this is actually a package a
comprehensive approach and that has to
be taken up once again and we must work
on this I made that appeal at the United
Nations so it's a very complicated
situation question is also very broad in
a sense I I try to give you a broader
answer it's a topic you that is of
interest to us currently and we are
accused to because of the vote against
the sanctions that they went but the
vote at the UN has actually given us
some room for a little bit of progress
since then and there were some positive
developments President Obama in his
address to the General Assembly
yesterday said that the window of the
diplomatic opportunity is still open and
if the window is open and if there is
perhaps slow but some positive progress
that has been because of turkeys effort
and it was turkeys the way turkey dealt
with this issue with its neighbor the
president mr. president Google I very
much appreciate your spending this time
of this I know you you have to go I want
to say that it's a terrific of you to
come into this environment and take
questions and hard questions and
difficult issues and in this heat we try
to keep the heat about 90 degrees in
here so that everybody feels it and I
would just say in conclusion that we've
had seven eight years of world leaders
coming through here we know that you
were once a professor and you are the
only world leader to ever not only quote
Foucault but to rely on him in your text
so you made us feel all at home
thank you thank you very much
you